esta es la escena que se puede ver esta
mañana en la ciudad de de niro donde
anoche se dio ese gran ataque en la
parte es residencial de la ciudad las
autoridades hablan de seis misiles
cuatro de ellos interceptados cuyos
restos habrían caído en las diferentes
partes de esta ciudad la cuarta más
grande de ucrania la ciudad industrial y
bastante extensa que está convertido en
el pulmón para dar todo ese apoyo
logístico a la región del donbass cerca
de aquí todos de esos otros misiles
habrían caído en esta parte que está a
mis espaldas no tenemos autorización de
firmarlo esta mañana pero lo que sí se
sabe es que uno de sus misiles cayó en
el centro de la calle dejando un gran
cráter allí impacto en un automóvil que
pasaba que quedó totalmente calcinado
otros automóviles en la vida también
quedaron quemados y se habla de tres
personas fallecidas uno de ellos un
conductor de autobuses públicos que en
ese momento había terminado su trabajo y
otra edificación sumada a las
residencias que aquí sería una fábrica
de las cuales hay varias nosotros cuando
salíamos ayer del lugar vimos diferentes
explosiones como si estuviera explotando
pólvora como consecuencia del calor la
gente corrió volvió a buscar refugio en
sus casas o en el metro pero hoy amanece
todo más tranquilo se está a la espera
de que lleguen equipos de investigación
para saber realmente qué fue lo que pasó
en este lugar